My name is Tom Mock.
I'm the Workbench product
manager here at Posit.
I kind of built my
career thinking about the developer experience.
So worked in the Quarto team
as a product manager thinking
about how we integrate R
and Python together for notebooks
and extending them,
and now I'm focusing almost
all of my time on the developer
experience for Workbench.
And integrating R and Python
there for data scientists and
their daily work.
Posit Team is kind of our
crown jewel or bundle of all
of our professional products.
So you have three kind of
parts to this that all are
complementary, but
also isolated products.
So maybe you only need one
or maybe you need all of them.
But y'all get to make that
choice in terms of flexibility.
So Posit Workbench
is your workbench,
where your data scientists,
your data analysts,
the people who write R, Python,
SQL, they get their work done.
We provide an authenticated
workspace with, you know,
best-in-class enterprise, single
sign-on, and SAML,
and the things
you would expect.
But we also provide
multiple environments for those data
scientists to get their
work done. So, of course,
you have RStudio for people who are
maybe doing a mix of R and
Python. You can
execute code there.
We've also got more traditional
and kind of expected pure
Python environments.
So we have access to Jupyter
Lab as well as classic Jupyter notebooks.
And then VS Code,
which is this very open
ended and flexible integrated
development environment is
also available on Workbench.
Positive Workbench
provides an IDE,
VS Code, Jupyter, Jupyter Labs,
or RStudio some place to
do that work. Eventually though,
you wanna get it off
of that environment,
where you can both track how
it's performing there,
but also how it affects
part of your business,
or integrate with other
parts of your company.
So as soon as you're ready
to get it off of your local
environment, you can
deploy it to Connect.
You can have a command line
where you kind of write it up
the application and then you
deploy it with authentication into Connect.
But you can also integrate it
into version control or kind of
continuous integration
and continuous deployment,
where it goes into something
like GitHub or GitLab and then
gets pulled automatically
into Connect.
The last part of it
would be Posit Package Manager. Again,
with open source, you
have all flexibility,
but with flexibility
can sometimes come complexity.
Package Manager is really this
backbone behind all of our
other tooling. Ultimately, to
do open source data science,
you need open source data
science libraries and packages.
So Posit Package Manager allows
you to host both your own
Python packages, so you
can create your own wheels,
upload them to Posit Package
Manager and have them stored
there, as well as grab subsets
or all of PyPi, and kind of
the other open source packages that
the whole community is working on.
So that really takes away a
lot of the headache of having
to manage more complex
structures like you don't have
to use Docker, you don't
have to use tools like Conda.
You don't have to manage all
these system dependencies
you're really focused on
purely writing Python code and
indicating what are the
libraries or packages that
provide the
functionality I want.
So Python at its most simple
is part of what Posit Team provides for you.
Posit historically has been
known for the RStudio IDE,
that's kind of our crown jewel
of developer experience for R users.
We've done a lot of investments
for Python users as well,
however. And so we have
Quarto, we have Vetiver,
we have all these open source
tools that really try to make
data science seamless
for Python users.
So part of our investment in
open source is that we are both
doing it ourselves
and integrating with others.
So if you think about
Posit the company,
about half of our
company's engineering,
and about half of our engineers
are working purely on open source.
So we're making huge
investments in terms of people
hours in improving,
and maintaining
professionally supported open source
data science packages. Over time,
you might have shifts in
how you're developing your your
tooling or writing your models,
and we want to kind of
future proof the platform so that as
new frameworks come out,
we're adding those in
and making sure that they're
supported and we're
testing against them,
as well as allowing them to
be deployed into things on production.